toet paper has no business trying to
battle the mess of a large holiday meal
but days on the other hand shoot a
precise I the happened to me I'm a
good guy I went to a good college I
worked hard I wrote a thesis in
college I wrote a thesis I've worked
hard for years I've raised a family I've
never gone to jail I've never committed
a crime and here I am explaining how you
got to shoot water up your
ass
ridiculous
Insanity what did I do what am I some
kind of I I don't understand how' this
happen toilet paper has no business
trying to battle the mess of a large
holiday meal do you know what they're
implying they're implying that if I eat
a large large holiday meal I just am
going to my my Bottom's going to explode
it's going to be too much for any toilet
paper no toilet paper can handle that no
you need a whole other device I'm crying
you need a
bedet that shoots
water no more smearing it says here on
the copy no more skid
marks what happened to this the precise
stream a precise
stream Buck pet oh here we go is the
number one bestselling pet brand and I
thought I had sold out can I just say
they say people will laugh when they
first see it and we sure did we we
haven't even seen
it 3 million satisfied customers across
the US and over 150,000 festar reviews
on Amazon who uses a bedet and then says
I've got to go give an Amazon
review I've checked back there seven
times clean as a
whistle my
this
is I'm going to keep going cuz people
are laughing too hard Lux pet offers a
range of patented bedet mods oh really
including the award-winning neop plus
series what does that do yeah the bedet
comes and finds you when it's time to
poop I think you should go really I
think you should go that was a large
burrito Lux Pet's neop plus series is
the next generation of attachment with
never before seen patented features
that's right never before seen this
series features a
360° selfclean mode easy
360° self clean mode are people spitting
around on their ass easy lift design
fast slide in installation plus all the
same features as their bestselling B
days
oh my
God then it says please talk about what
you why you love your Lux pet I don't
have one but this is my favorite ad ever
this is a fantastic ad and this is going
to go out as it is or it won't go out
get the gifts your friends and family
will never forget this holiday season
hey Grandma wash your
ass use code na to get 20% off pday at
Lux pay.com
that's
lxb
d.com and code n/a for 20% off they made
me spell
[Applause]
B you just have to that airs as is or it
doesn't
air